I got an email from somebody saying hey
we met at this beverage server and I
started looking at these waveforms they
were just actually spectacular it stops
right out and that was amazing to us and
people took note of that I shouldn't
took note but I thought it wasn't real
and then when you start doing the test
when you found that all the conditions
you had the status code then you began
to believe we will want to test
Einstein's field equations and the one
way to really test the field equations
was to find a blackboard we don't want a
satisfaction that this was all dreamt up
by this guy with pure thought means it's
sort of creepy when you think about in
1915 and he couldn't have known that
this is the statistic whatever be tested
this way and yes it comes out right on
the money which is really not okay to me
that's a little bit more it's this
miraculous
my god this may be it the signal was so
strong to have it all come together in
this one event on September 4th
it's just profoundly satisfying because
we've been trying to keep this a secret
for a long time
it's not been easy
we've begun with the
field which was had a huge amount of
effort got into it both on the
experimental side in the simulation side
but it was all in preparation for this
day well in the beginning I thought it
was a mistake I thought somebody had
made the test and push the mirror or
simulating a gravitational wave but it
took only few hours until I realized
that that was not the case
nobody was craziness from that time and
since now we have been working so hard
to get the details right to convince
ourselves that this was not the
disturbance this was not an accident
it's just this was it because we made
that to convince the world
so we first of all the paper understands
it for fear with you before before
telling you about it because we just
wanted to be a hundred percent sure it's
the beginning of a new era just
beginning we are taking off now with we
have detectors that measure
gravitational waves so we won't stop
measuring we get more and more of these
we will make our the textures better and
better we will be better than bigger
detectors we will help all these other
windows the colony
that are doing the Pulsar timing and and
the space detector we are all in this
together
[Music]
[Music]